there was this big uproar about people
being mad that game said that he thinks
he's the greatest
rapper ever come out at compton i'm like
he's supposed to say that like
like well because he was on he was on
clubhouse and and and what he's
what he said about like yo i'm the
hardest to ever come out of confidence
i'm gonna tell you listen
i'm gonna kind of give you some insight
on that right because first thing people
gonna think is uh
uh kendrick lamar well i personally
think kendrick
as from and i think i think games right
there
i'm gonna tell y'all but game should say
that right i'm gonna tell you why he
says that
before it was a kendrick lamar was a
k-dot right
the kid k-dot now we go back to the game
50 situation
was a student of games no i don't took
him on tour
lax store anybody knew who he was and
all this right now extort was nipsy
j-rocky [ __ ] up kate out as humble as
he
is he probably would never answer the
question because i really think
kdot is in a lane of his own a mountain
of his own you're talking
two different type of rappers right kdot
is a legend
and my book is coming out the west coast
and he's still got a whole lot of life
in him for sure shout out to tde top dog
in the whole family over there
but game is always um
he's like like you won't catch you can't
get top dog to say
i'm a bigger record exec than sugar
knight
and he's moved some numbers right
because
suge knight was a teacher to us all
he's somebody we watched that we talked
to that we consoled it right
as big as top dog is he won't say that
right and he got some real stats that he
can stand on
so when it comes to game when he sees
kendrick no matter how big he get it's
kind of like
my son my son taller than me getting
bigger than me
that's still my son i'mma respect him
because he's my son he's a product of me
not to say gang built kendrick
but he was a a vital tool
in the growth of kendrick well i mean i
i remember that
that moment that moment when on stage
when
kendrick officially got past the torch
when kendrick crystal ain't gonna have
to do that that was a big moment
but listen snoop dead stoop already he's
i can't first of course you know he can
rap don't wrap his icon
right cube everybody there at the time
game was still
grinding yeah but game did that because
this is one of his mans you know what
i'm saying hey i want to see you grow
right you know i mean so he's never
going to put himself
behind kendrick and i don't think
kendrick will ever put himself
ahead of game i think it's really a
mutual respect for it
to the teacher's student thing to you
know the big homie little homie type
type situation as if i don't think
kendrick will ever talk down on j-rock
of course not yet because he was once j
rock's height man now we look at numbers
we'll say oh [ __ ] kendricks and j
rock right but without that j-rock
element well j-rock is the first guy
to kick the whole [ __ ] off yeah without
that j-rock element
right they would there wouldn't have
been
that initial seeding nurturing of
kendrick lamar